you know i was never a very good student
of physics in high school or of any
other subject frankly but one thing i
know is that um when an object starts
falling its velocity will increase the
rate of its descent will only accelerate
until it hits the ground and i've
noticed a similar thing happens with
wokeness leftism has its own
gravitational pull which ensures that
once a person organization falls into
the woke pits it will tumble towards
annihilation at ever-increasing speeds
but also there really is no ground in
this scenario leftism is more of a black
hole i guess you fall endlessly into the
darkness until you're ripped apart and
the pieces of you disintegrate and
become one with the abyss we're watching
this play out right now across our
culture disney is just one case study
but a rather instructive one now it's
true that disney has been liberal
probably since walt himself died but
they've mostly sort of been orbiting
around the black hole approaching it in
a somewhat controlled manner
but then the parental rights bill in
florida came along prohibiting teachers
from talking to five-year-olds about
their sexuality uh disney facing
pressure from a small cluster of lgbt
lgbt extremists in their organization
had to make a choice
they could try to remain neutral which
would keep them in orbit around the
black hole of wokeness or they could
actively push back against the lgbt
militants which was never going to
happen but if they did it would actually
move them farther away from that black
hole or they could cave to the radical
gay factions and come out fully in favor
of teaching seven-year-olds about
transgenderism and gender fluidity
they of course chose the latter option
which meant diving right into the hole
and now they're in the midst of an
ideological free-fall
this is what lgbt activists want they
don't want you orbiting around the
perimeter they insist that you surrender
to their demands and reorganize your
whole life or your whole organization or
both
in whatever way they require
so investigative journalist chris
through foe has obtained footage
that shows just how rapid this dissent
has been
according to rufo disney recently called
an all hands meeting where multiple
executives and other high high-ranking
people in the institution talked about
what disney would do
going forward
to cater to the gay agenda
unless you think i'm exaggerating or
engaging in conspiracy theories with the
phrase gay agenda you should realize
that the term was actually used in the
meeting
here's executive producer latoya raveno
uh and and here she is listen
it's like i love disney's content i grew
up watching you know all of the classics
they have been a huge like informative
part of my life but at the same time
like i worked at small studios most of
my career and i'd heard you know you
hear whispers like i'd heard things like
oh you know they won't let you show this
at a disney show and i'm like okay so i
was a little like suss when i started
and but then
my experience was
bafflingly the opposite of what i had
heard on my little pocket of like you
know proud family disney tva
um
the showrunners were super welcoming
meredith roberts and like the our
leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda and so like i i feel
like
i felt like it was i mean like maybe it
was that way in the past but i guess
like something must have happened in the
last like like they're turning it around
they're going hard
now
uh she says disney is going hard on the
gay agenda
and
no further comment needed but as bad as
that is and as disturbing is the way she
phrased it
still somehow the most troubling thing
in that video is that a grown woman is
speaking with the language and
mannerisms of a 14 year old on tick tock
but if you're wondering what the gay
agenda might look like in practice or
sound like
disney diversity and inclusion manager
vivian ware appeared later in the
meeting to give just one example of how
this gay agenda may be put into practice
listen
last summer we removed all of the um
gendered greetings in relationship to
our life skills so we no longer say
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls um
we we've trained we provided training
for all of our our cast members in
relationship to that so now they know
it's it's hello everyone or hello
friends we we are in the process of
changing over those those recorded
messages and so many of you are probably
familiar when we brought the fireworks
back to the magic kingdom we no longer
say ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
we say dreamers of all ages and so i
love the fact that it's opened up the
creativity the opportunity for our cast
members to look at that we we have our
cast members working with merchandise
working with food and beverage working
with with all of our guest spacing areas
where perhaps you know we want to create
that magical moment with our cast
members with our guests
and we don't want to just assume because
someone might be um in in our
interpretation may be presenting as
female that they may not want to be
called princess so let's think
differently about how do we really
engage with our guests in a meaningful
and inclusive way that makes it magical
and memorable for everyone
yes well we all know that nothing upsets
a little girl at disney world more than
being called princess i mean they just
hate that
good thing disney has done away with
such slurs although i should warn them
that everyone they said we're going to
say everyone instead of ladies and
gentlemen well um that's not going to be
an acceptable alternative because
everyone implies that each individual
identifies as being just a single entity
this could be quite othering to the
self-identified days and thems in the
audience not to mention anybody with
disassociative identity disorder
every one is not only exclusionary and
transphobic but also ableist
now at another point in the meeting
disney production coordinator alan march
made an appearance where he assured the
assembled staff that his team has
created a tracker to ensure that disney
is telling a sufficient number of queer
stories listen
yeah um i've had the privilege of
working with the moon girl team for the
last two years
and they've been really open to
exploring queer stories and part of i'm
on the production side uh part of uh the
work that i feel like i can put in is um
making sure that we take place in modern
day new york so making sure that that's
like an accurate reflection of new york
so i put together like a tracker of our
background characters to make sure that
we have like a the full breadth of
expression and uh we got into a very
similar conversation carrie of like
oh
all of our
like gender non-conforming characters
are in the background and so it's not
just a numbers game
of how many lgbtq plus characters you
have
we got
the further
uh the the more centered a story is on a
character the more nuanced you get to
get into their story and especially with
like trans characters you can't see if
someone is trans there's not one way to
look trans and so kind of the only way
to have these like canonical trans
characters canonical asexual characters
canonical bisexual characters is to give
them stories where they can like be
their whole selves
so this is where you end up when you
free fall into woke leftism you end up
using phrases like canonical asexual
characters
although that phrase is not nearly as
disturbing as something uttered by
disney corporate president kerry burke
listen to this i'm here as a mother of
two queer children actually um uh one
transgender child um
[Music]
and one pansexual child um and and also
as a leader
um and that was the thing that really
got me because i have heard so much from
so many of my colleagues over the course
of the last couple weeks
um in open forums and through emails and
phone conversations and
um i feel a responsibility to speak um
not just for myself but for them
to all of us we had a we had an open
forum last week at 20th where
um
again the home of really incredible
groundbreaking
lgbtqia stories over the years where
um one of our execs stood up and said
you know we only have a handful of queer
leads in our content and i went what
that can't be true and i and i and i
realized oh it actually is true
yes um
pansexual child
is what she said
now please keep this in mind if your kid
is watching disney content he is
watching content produced by people who
believe in the existence of pansexual
children
now
the word pansexual of course in reality
means nothing at all it's nonsense but
according to the left in their fantasy
world a pansexual is somebody who quote
is not limited in sexual choice with
regard to biological sex gender or
gender identity
i mean the story of peter pan begins to
take on a whole new meaning
and so miss kerry burke says that
there's that her her child an actual
child
is not limited in his sexual choice by
biological sex or gender identity this
is how she speaks of children her own
children
and she has two children who are both
queer quote unquote one pansexual the
other trans how in god's name do you end
up with two children who allegedly
identify themselves with these
alternative sexual labels
well it happens because you select it
for them you hand that identity to them
the way that you might buy a child a new
jacket and tell them to put it on a
child is not going to come up with the
concept of pansexuality on his own any
more than he's going to come up with
transgenderism
those must be given to him we talk about
things being assigned to children well
that is
assigned he has to be converted into it
because as i've argued many times the
real conversion therapy that happens in
our world today is the kind where a
child is converted into lgbt
now in a normal in an insane world the
woman in that video would be in prison
right now on charges of child abuse
instead she's a well-compensated
executive at a billion dollar multimedia
company in charge of creating
entertainment for children
she also says later in the clip that she
wants to have um half of disney's
characters
by the end of the year be lgbt or
minorities
half of them now this would seem to be
in conflict with the whole concept of a
minority
if the idea is simply representation
then why is there this push for over
representation why the insistence on
making these identities more prominent
on screen than they are in real life
well
here's the important point when these
people talk about representation
they don't mean that they want the
characters and storylines to represent
america as it currently is
they want it to represent the kind of
world and culture they wish to create
they're not representing culture they're
making it
they want to have a whole lot more quote
lgbt children which means putting a lot
more of it on the screen
they want to reshape the world which
means reshaping your child
the only question now is whether you as
a parent
are going to let them do it well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content